the Joe Rogan experience also oddly
enough I think that part of what makes
MMA so exciting is that there is crazy
consequences are the reasons why when
you see like Maz Vidal knocks out Ben
Askren with that flying knee part of why
I was so exciting like oh he's hurt bad
yeah it's not that he's gonna be fine
nothing's no damage from this whatsoever
like no that's real damage like he went
out cold
instantly and then he got punched in the
face twice it's part of what it's
terrible but it's part of what makes the
sport so exciting is that you realize
these guys are so brave to face these
potential consequences you know makes it
it makes it it's like an added element
of danger that makes it exciting it's
very true but it's man I feel so bad for
him with that when I saw that cause it
kind of brought back memories for myself
I was like ah I know exactly what that
moment feels like I don't remember it
but I know exactly what that moment
feels like when you fought more eyes do
you remember what happened up to that
yeah and you just don't remember it
landing I saw like right before lens and
it was like you know in those movies
when it goes it was at this very moment
[Laughter]
yeah and out like a light man and I
didn't like come to and like I mean I
woke up but I didn't come to like
actually remember like [ __ ] I wasn't a
fistfight and I lost like really bad
like really quick when I got to a
hospital and I glanced when you realized
it yeah I heard Ben say the same thing I
was like this is not just me I guess
it's just a really bad knock out him
shooting forward and Maz Vidale jumping
into him like a car crash man in Moscow
dogs running full clip that's a 40-yard
dash running full clip and perfect
placement the knee I mean you don't get
a cleaner knockout no and just the way
he did it like he was shown the video of
him practicing it and saying he had like
three different scenarios of how that
situation could have went that's like
masterful thinking and tactical like
there's not a lot of people who are
that's Reber when it comes to the game
and I think the way he broke that down
was just super impressive and he kind of
lulled him to sleep like his hands
behind his back I loved there
second of that because you weren't sure
what was about to happen I was on the
edge of my seat that was my main event
fight and then he just comes out takes a
side stuff like just drifts off to the
right and then boom 40-yard dash and
whiney kale it was just as much a main
event for me too because it's so
important for the welterweight division
yeah whereas like John Jones versus
Thiago Santos it was an interesting
fight and turned out to be a great fight
but it was an interesting fight because
you're like okay how is John Jones gonna
beat this guy and is this guy gonna be
wild enough to catch John Jones but when
you looked at it on paper John was a
prohibitive favorite yeah when you
looked at a screen versus moskvin all
you're like man I don't know
[Applause]